I shot my special. Let me start with this dude. I shot my special,
uh, Saturday now I don't know what I'm going to call it,
but I don't think I've ever had a better
taping. You know, just the, the, the comedy,
all the comedy that could go wrong. It just kind of aligned. I was relaxed.
The first show I went on, my brother directed it, but first show I went on.
It was good, really good. I got off stage. And my, my agent was like,
that's the best, first show taping I've ever seen? And I was like, really?
And he was like, yup. And then I was like,
and then I was like, cool. So we got to only need pieces.
And when he needs pieces, he needs pieces. That's all they need.
So he's relaxed, dude.
So your boy's relaxed now.
You know, the whole mantra of life rips, you realize, you know what,
this is one of those moments where life does actually rep.
So the boy needs pieces and he's going on stage for the second show.
And he's seen his head. He's like, Oh, I only need pieces.
And then he gets on stage. And as soon as he gets on stage, dude,
he realizes he only needs like two pieces. And that's when he just ripped.
And that's when the repped and in the middle of the second show, I thought, Hey,
you know what? I tapped,
I tapped God on the shoulder and I go, Hey God, guess what?
We don't even need that first show.
So.
That second one was the reprimand. That first show was ripping,
but that second show was the ripper.
So that was just an,
I got off stage and I go, Hey, we don't need that first show. Like I was,
the first show was great,
but the second show made us not need the first
show.
[Inaudible].
Um, so yeah, it was awesome, dude. It was, it was so awesome. So happy.
I was so happy man had some loved ones.
There was just happy, man. My brother killed it.
Um, and that's it.
I couldn't ask for more so I can't wait for you guys to see it. It looks cool.
I had the Jordan, the purple retro ones on
to help me pivot. Um,
and let's see, uh, I don't know what else to say about it,
but I woke up. That was the thing I kept on. Like I, as the days went on too,
I was like, I just, I hope I don't get sick.
That's the only thing that would this up.
I've worked so hard to get this going to get the, um, uh,
material sharpest. I did a 10, 11 day run before the show.
I did some casinos coupled with some theaters and I was like,
don't get sick. Don't get chapped lips, dude. Sure enough.
The second I got off stage on that second show,
my lips go like this and just cracked now.
That's that's Jesus Christ working with you. That's Jesus Christ.
Just kinda, it just kind handed you a couple of of a sword of his,
some assorted nuts. That's what he's doing.
Jesus Christ is just handing you some sword, assorted nuts.
Now can I say a sorted nuts or can I only say a sword nuts?
And now that me off that it sounds like when I'm saying assorted nuts,
it sounds like I'm saying a sword and nuts. Okay.
But I mean, assorted nuts. So that's like,
when you're just kind of hungry walking through the airport,
you don't know what to get and Jesus Christ just walks up to you and hands you
some assorted nuts. Right? So that's what that was.
That was Jesus Christ. Just kind of working with you,
like you're in a cubicle and you're typing it.
Maybe you're in a cubicle right now and you're like, I need that. Hey Susan,
can you hear me? The?
And Susan just reaches over the top of the divider and hinges the that's what's
happening right now.
That's Jesus Christ handing you some assorted nuts.
So it was, I got off the second stage Melissa goes and I go, doesn't matter,
does it? No. Cause when my lip cracks, we know babies,
my lip cracks where it always cracks. And it's going to,
you're going to see that on that high-def camera. Uh,
so I woke up feeling good that day and I was ready. I flew from,
well, I guess it took the Chicago airport to, uh, because I was in new Buffalo,
Michigan for some reason. And I went to the, we, we drove to Chicago
and we went to the dude. I got, I took my,
my tour manager was with us. Cause we were doing like at a 10, 11 day run, Zack,
Don Coveo. And um, that's how he laughs. If you don't remember.
And the guy is just the worst tour manager of all time, dude, straight up.
He's always the last one for, to the bus, to the sprinter van, to the airport.
He's like, we're like, I'm like where the is Zack? And Mike said, I don't know,
man. And then he shows up with like, just,
he always looks like he's carrying seven bags,
even though he's only carrying like two bags and he's just like, Oh yeah. Oh,
I forgot my ID. He's like one of those that doesn't keep the ID and the wallet,
you know, those guys keep your ID in your wallet. Don't have your ID.
Don't be the guy who comes out and brings your ID. The, and some cash, you know,
I'm talking about and he'll be like, Oh, I'm a wallet. We're in a casino.
We're staying in a casino. We were staying at the MGM grand and in Detroit.
And I'll be like, let's go get a coffee. And it's in the casino.
And he'll be like, all right, let's go. And then I'll go down the elevator.
And then we get to the thing, Oh, you know what? I forgot my ID.
I'm 37. She's like, sweetheart, I need the ID. And I'm like, well,
I have it, man. You should always have it ID on you man. And he was like, well,
I don't know it was in the bag because I had to,
because it was my money and I don't know. Hey. And so I I'm like,
I'm not waiting for you, bro, bro. I'm going to leave him at the hotel one day.
I'm gonna leave him at the hotel. See the thing is,
he's got some of my bags sometimes. So that's, what's it.
I'm going to take all my bags one night and then we get to the sprinter van.
Zack's not going to be there. I'm going to say, Hey Mike, where's Zach.
He's gonna be like, I don't know, man.
He was shuffling around in the hotel room doing some. Oh,
he takes so long, bro. We could be in a green room and I'll be like,
let's go downstairs to see where the is. And we'll be like, okay.
And I'll walk down the hallway and I'll look,
I'll do the thing where I look behind to the green room and he's still not out
yet. Do you know what I'm talking about?
You get out of the green room and then you walk out.
It's like when you leave a room and you're waiting for somebody and you walk
down the hallway,
but you're still looking at the room's door and he's still not there.
And you're all the way down the hallway. Hey man. Get with it. Dude.
Always know where your ideas to do. You know why it's your ID?
If there's one thing you should always have on you besides pants
have your ID on you.
My podcast is musical.
My podcast is musical. That's probably why I don't like music.
All that much dude. But you saw your boy when he used the mic. When he was like,
Hey ants, who other, what other podcasts host is doing that.
That's because we're down for a syllabus time and that's it. And life rips. Now,
dude, I've been seeing people on Instagram, start podcasts,
talking about silly goose times,
talking about how life's reps talking about using my cadence. And that's fine,
dude, because people know where you got it from and it's all gravy.
Okay. But just so you know, we all know and that's fine. Rep the call, do it.
Whatever. Sometimes people use it and they are disgusting with it.
Sometimes people use the way I talk and they start talking about Blumkins or
something. No, we don't do that, dude.
We don't talk about the Lumpkins here at the log cabin. I'm a classy guy.
I'm a classic man. What's that song? [inaudible]
I'm a classic man. Anyway, dude,
we don't talk about Blumkins man. We don't talk about gross. You know,
maybe I might mention, you should take some Metamucil if you're trying to,
you know, take some nice bowel movements, but I don't talk about Blumkins.
I don't talk about Lena pluses that much. And I don't,
I don't, I would never say something like Grundle. You know what I mean?
Like I'm not a frat guy. How many? The guy who goes like this,
the guy who talks about a Grundle is a guy who goes like this when something's
funny, the whole man that's classic.
That guy says Grundle so much and I don't do that. You know how I go, man?
You know how I go all I want, you know what I realized, man,
I was coming up in the comedy world, like whatever, my, my, my brother and I,
we have this way of talking and it, it, it, you know, my friends,
we all have it. And I was like, ah, I want to do,
I w I wish the world knew my language now, baby.
I made the podcast. Now the world knows my language. Okay. I did it.
I didn't know I could do it, but it did it. If you build it, they will come.
But I woke up feeling so good. I woke up feeling so good. Three days,
my special,
I woke up feeling two days before my special and the day of my special,
I woke up feeling good. Now I got a question for you, scientists.
Why does that happen? How come sometimes you get lots of sleep. You feel good.
Sometimes you get lots of sleep. You feel bad. Sometimes you get a little sleep.
You feel good. Sometimes you get a little sleep, you feel bad. What's the deal.
Why do I sleep better in hotel beds than I do in my own bed? What's the deal?
Do I need a new mattress? Maybe, but mattresses are thousands of dollars.
So that's a little bit weird for a test of something to be a thousand, $2,000.
How much is a mattress on? And I'm so out of touch. I don't give a.
How much is a carton of milk? $45.
[Inaudible].
Um, I'll cough on your do, but yeah, it's uh,
um.
You.
Know, it's, it is what it is, man,
but I had a good special taping and it was awesome.
And I woke up feeling so good.
And my buddy Mike went on before me and he was like, don't, we'll do the word,
no woos on my last special, there were wounds, bro.
I hate when people go, woo.
You're not at the nets game. Why are you going? Woo.
Dicamba [inaudible] is an onstage.
And um, yeah, dude, Hey, why are you going?
Whoa, Jay Buner isn't out on this field.
And so, yeah, it really me off when they go, Whoa. And they were,
there was no woos there. I think there was one, we were on the second show.
Somebody got kicked, thrown out. Apparently imagine being that big of an,
he was talking loud, I'm a manager, walked out to him. He was there.
He was like, I ended it on someone else. And there was my out, you know,
and the guy was like, he was, I was like, what happened? He was like,
he was just being loud. Okay. And he got up Linda, the bathroom dude.
I didn't come back. He was like, where's my seat.
We put somebody else they're being really loud on. Right. So, you know,
out. And he was like, well, can I just go back to get my stuff? And I was like,
sure, what your stab is, hold on. You know? And he's like, where is it?
And he's like, well, look, I don't know. I've got a wallet, my money,
my ID in there, you know? And I got it. Anyway,
we found out he he's being loud. And I was like, Oh yeah, that's carry mom. So,
and uh, I don't, if it's gonna work out on, you know,
I knew it and it sounds like it's gonna be fine. Okay. But,
and uh, and so he threw him out, dude, he's a bulldog man. My manager's good.
Josh Lieberman. And um, so anyway, tossed him out. It was all good.
Didn't really hear it. He kind of. He said,
I think I heard something in the first show. I think it might,
might've heard him get a little loud at the first show,
but how could you be that ego? I get not egotistical,
but self-centered to be like making a scene at the Netflix special
taping.
Anyway. Um.
Yeah. So laughing, don't laugh. Like I always say.